die kanzlerin hat im jahr 2015 gesagt
wir schaffen das meingast boris palmer
hat gesagt wir schaffen das nicht
herr kaymer nach drei jahren was ist ihr
resümee welcher satz ist richtig wir
haben es geschafft aber nur weil die
kanzlerinnen den hilferuf der kommunen
erhört hat und die grenzen wieder unter
kontrolle gebracht dadurch sind die
zahlen so weit nach unten gegangen dass
wir das heute wieder beherrschen können
sie haben in der ganzen menge an
aussagen sagt 2015 vorher auch aber
gerade im zusammenhang mit der migration
großes aufsehen erregt vor allen dingen
weil sie als grüner durchaus bestimmten
aussagen der grünen spitze der partei
selber widersprochen haben
haben sie den eindruck das ist eben
anders wenn man vor ort ist wenn man als
oberbürgermeister sie sind mit großer
großer mehrheit wiedergewählt worden von
über 60 prozent der ware tagtäglich mit
den menschen zu tun hat
das ist eine andere realität ja das ist
in allen parteien so ich habe letztes
jahr sigmar gabriel gehört wie er auf
dem deutschen städtetag gesagt hat er
meine es sei notwendig dass alle die im
bundestag gewählt werden wollen vorher
mindestens ein einjähriges
pflichtpraktikum in einer kommune machen
und wir müssen als kommunalpolitiker
immer wieder sagen so ist es wirklich so
ist es vor ort so wirken die gesetze
weil wir ansonsten mit dem problem nicht
fertig werden darin habe ich meine
aufgaben auch meine verpflichtungen
gesehen selbst dann wenn das im herbst
2015 meine partei sehr verärgert hat sie
haben ganz am anfang und wir haben ja
vor drei jahren schon mal miteinander
gesprochen sehr lange in dieser sendung
gesagt vor allen dingen wir haben
wohnraum problemen das ist das was am
ehesten 2015 das drängendste der
probleme war dabei ja noch eine große
euphorie da wir helfen denen die müssen
aus kriegsgebieten doch schutz bekommen
bei uns hat sich die probleme verlagert
inzwischen ja wir hatten damals das
akute problem die leute überhaupt
irgendwie unterzubringen
deswegen haben wir turnhallen belegt das
ist in deutschland vorbei die menschen
sind jetzt in ordentlichen wohnungen
untergebracht haben den tübingern zum
beispiel in drei jahren jetzt wohnungen
für über 1000 bewerber neu gebaut bei
90.000 einwohnern und ungefähr 50
sozialwohnungen die wir pro jahr
normalerweise bauen das ist eine riesen
wir haben das geschafft aber wir haben
jetzt neue probleme probleme haben sich
verschoben ist jeder zwei hauptthemen
zum einen die frage was ist denn mit
bezahlbarem wohnraum für die die nicht
zugewandert sind sondern von schon
vorher schon da waren da haben wir ein
riesiges problem risiken sozialen
sprengstoff und zum anderen wie gehen
wir mit der kleinen aber sehr
problematischen gruppe der flüchtlinge
um die in unserem land kriminell werden
und schwere straftaten begehen da
bleiben wir mal bei dem ersten problem
wir haben ja den vorwurf die die da
kommen kommen aus kriegsgebieten den
wollen wir helfen aber den geht es ja
besser als denen denen es hier nicht gut
geht
so ist es nicht aber es ist schon so
dass man schwer entkräften kann ein
gefühl benachteiligt zu werden wenn
leute seit jahren auf eine sozialwohnung
warten wenn sie ein kind kriegen und
dann in der zwei zimmer wohnung bleiben
müssen weil sie keine größere finden wie
sie die stadt verlassen müssen weil da
nichts bezahlbares mehr für sie ist und
nebendran werden neubauwohnungen für
geflüchtete hergestellt das kann man
schwer erklären
wir kommen nicht darum herum diese
wohnungen für die geflüchteten zu bauen
das muss sein weil die haben ja gar kein
dach über den kopf wenn wir nichts tun
aber dass das untere einkommensdrittel
unserer gesellschaft dafür einen preis
zahlt das darf nicht sein und deswegen
muss die gesellschaft jetzt sehr viel
mehr anstrengungen unternehmen um
bezahlbaren wohnraum für alle zu
schaffen
sie haben relativ klare worte gefunden
zu denen die nach deutschland kommen die
asyl beantragen und relativ schnell sich
mit verschiedensten straftaten hervortun
wir haben einen satz vor wenigen wochen
beim grünen parteitag im zusammenhang
mit dem grünen parteitag ist der
ministerpräsident kretschmann gefragt
worden und hat gesagt ja wir müssen
eigentlich diese jungen horden in die
pampa schicken das hat einen großen
aufschrei bei den grünen hervorgerufen
ist das ein satz den sie mit
unterschreiben würden er selbst sagt er
wird heute nicht mehr so ausdrücken aber
was er damit gemeint hat ist meiner
auffassung nach vollkommen richtig sei
aber dass im zeitungsinterview er war
gar nicht auf den parteitagen nur
zufällige
zeitgleichheit worum geht's wir stellen
fest dass 15 prozent der schweren
straftaten tötungsdelikte
gewaltverbrechen und vergewaltigungen
von flüchtlingen begangen werden die
seen aber nur zwei prozent der
bevölkerung das heißt wir haben es ja
mit einer massiven erhöhung der
häufigkeit zahlen zu tun
und das hat schon mal drei jahre lang
gebraucht dass man dieses phänomen dass
sich schulden von anfang an abgezeichnet
hat überhaupt mal als faktum anerkennt
da wurde viel zu lange drüber weg
geredet aber wurde hannes oder dann
nicht sogar verharren dann wurde es
verharmlost ja aber es war lange sodass
das aber es hat ins weltbild nicht
gepasst da kommen menschen die flüchten
vor krieg und verfolgung dann hat man
geglaubt sie würden sich bei uns auch
gut integrieren wird sind da halt
straftäter dabei und zwar viel mehr als
man normalerweise müsste so also das
faktum wird jetzt immerhin anderen kann
das mache ich jetzt als zweiten schritt
dann fragen wie lösen wir das problem
und das problem ist gar nicht so einfach
zu lösen denn wir haben jetzt noch eine
zusätzliche erkenntnis die schweren
straftaten begehen fast immer
flüchtlinge die vorher schon mit der
polizei und mit gerichten stress hatten
polizei bekannt waren schlimme
freiburger fall der vielfach
vergewaltigung da hatte der haupttäter
28 vorstrafen war aber nie im gefängnis
und das sind unsere gesetze nicht darauf
vorbereitet ich will jetzt aber keinen
liberalen staat geld das die gesetze das
ist durch die justiz ist nicht
vorbereitet die polizei ist er relativ
schnell und die zeit dabei
sie ermittelt sie kann festnehmen aber
dann kommt der zweite schritt nämlich
die aufnahme der justiz für diese
menschen und da fragt man sich natürlich
als bürger immer wie kann es dann sein
der wohnsitz ist angegeben und damit
dürfen die auch schon wieder direkt aus
dem polizeipräsidium raus aber das ist
ein problem der gesetzgeber wir haben
die liberalen rechtsstaat der wegen
kleinigkeiten nicht sofort mit der
schweren beute kommt das finde ich auch
richtig ist will ich nicht aufgeben und
wegen des gleichbehandlungsgrundsatzes
kann man die flüchtlinge nicht anders
behandeln da kommen aber viele
ausführlich totalitären gesellschaften
und die verstehen das falsche glauben
das sei die einladung weiter zu machen
und dann kommen sie auf eine schiefe
ebene und am ende ist ein messer gezückt
die frau vergewaltigt oder ein mensch
tot und da müssen wir intervenieren
früher und wie könnte das gehen wenn wir
nicht massive gesetzesverschärfungen
wollen dann müssen wir meiner meinung
nach din und wie es geht
rausnehmen aus den städten raus aus den
gemeinden und den einrichtungen bringen
die mit viel security und viel polizei
und einer partiellen ausgangssperre bei
nacht so gesichert sind dass keine
gefahr mehr für die bevölkerung von
diesen menschen ausgeht das sind wir den
schutz der menschen die hier geholfen
haben die hilfe bereitgestellt haben
meiner meinung nach schuldig aber jetzt
sagen ganz viele und nicht zuletzt auch
viele in der politik wir müssen die alle
abschieben
das ist ein verständlicher satz dass man
die kriminellen die gar kein
aufenthaltsrecht haben abschieben möchte
aber die praxis zeigt das gelingt eben
nur langsam und bei weitem nicht bei
allen
ich denke deswegen wir müssen erkennen
dass da wo papiere nicht zu beschaffen
sind die herkunftsstaaten nicht
mitmachen man gar nicht weiß in welches
land man diese menschen abschieben soll
dass wir probleme haben die nicht
schnell lösbar sind
das prägen brauchen wir etwas das in
dieser oft langen phase bis eine
abschiebung gelingt da können jahre ins
land gehen sicherstellt dass die
bevölkerung nicht mit straftaten den
preis dafür bezahlt deswegen der
vorschlag raus aus den städten rein ins
sichere einrichtungen
sie haben eben auch gesagt das ist ganz
wichtig sie haben direkt mit den bürgern
zu tun das ist nicht die berliner
politik sondern das ist die politik des
jähnigen der verantwortlich ist in der
kommune der direkt mit den bürgern
spricht wenn sie fälle haben wie in
freiburg in ellwangen
wie begegnen sie dann bürgern was fragen
die sie und wie antworten sie denen die
bürger wollen natürlich wissen was tun
sie zu unserem schutz oder warum es ist
nicht möglich zu unterbinden dass eine
gruppe von schwarzafrikanischen
asylbewerbern jeden tag im stadtpark
drogen handelt warum ist es nicht
möglich dagegen vorzugehen dass gruppen
junger männer in tübinger diskotheken
frauen anquatschen und erkennbar
asylbewerber jetzt dabei eine ganz
wichtige rolle spielen und die antwort
ist wir haben dafür in den kommunen nur
bedingt einsatzmöglichkeiten und
instrumente zur verfügung die will ich
alle nutzen wir haben zum beispiel die
kommunale polizei jetzt innerhalb
weniger jahre in der mannschaftsstärke
vervierfacht und die ist jetzt nachts
jede nacht unterwegs zeigt präsenz aber
an die strukturellen probleme kommen wir
als kommune nicht rein oder muss ich
leider sagen ich sehe ihr problem ich
will es auch lösen aber ich musste erst
bei land und bund sensibilität und
unterstützung gewinnen um mehr tun zu
können
das haben sie einen satz gesagt die
flucht nach deutschland war ein glück
für die flüchtlinge nicht für
deutschland
der ist zwar hart aber objektiv richtig
an der seite einer geschichte entgegen
gestellt sein ist ja aus meinem beruf
den sie kreist zitiert haben die so
getan hat als würde deutschland
bereichert als hätte deutschland größte
wirtschaftliche profite aus der
zuwanderung von arbeitskräften zu
erwarten das alles war von anfang an
nicht richtig und das hat sich jetzt
auch gezeigt dass wir langfristig mit
sehr viel unterstützung hohen kosten und
dauerhafter arbeitslosigkeit und
sozialtransfers rechnen müssen
das macht aber alles nichts aus wenn wir
dabei leben retten es ist doch ein glück
für diese menschen wenn sie von dem
krieg werden tatsächlich fliegen können
und das offen auszusprechen ich sehe
darin kein problem im gegenteil ich
glaube dass moralische mäntelchen um
sachverhalte zu holen damit man nicht
mehr so richtig darüber reden muss was
gut ist und was nicht so gut läuft das
hindert uns dabei die probleme im griff
zu bekommen haben was wünschen sie sich
denn dann wenn sie sagen eine stadt ist
ja im grunde genommen auch irgendwo ein
bisschen macht nur sie haben zwar gerade
beschrieben dass sie die sicherheit
erhöhen können aber wir haben 400.000
asylbewerber
das ist eine zahl von abgelehnten
asylbewerbern die man wie wir besprochen
haben ja nicht einfach abweisen kann und
ausweisen kann man muss also irgendeine
struktur finden wo wir eine größere
sicherheit herstellen können die ja auch
oft genug gar nicht mal eine objektive
problematik ist sondern eine subjektive
also wenn jemand zu ihnen kommt und sagt
für mich eigentlich in der stadt nicht
mehr so richtig sicher muss das ja gar
nicht so sein ist tatsächlich auch
objektiv nicht begründbar vor zehn
jahren hatten wir mehr schwere
straftaten in deutschland als heute aber
wenn dann drüber sich verunsichert fehlt
können sie ihn ja nicht sagen
bitte schauen sie doch mal in die
statistik sie fürchten sich zu unrecht
fürchtet euch nicht alles wird gut und
es gibt umfragen die zeigen dass die
hälfte der deutschen sagen
sicherheitsgefühl hat in den letzten
jahren deutlich gelitten das muss man
ernst nehmen das ist ein teil der
wirklichkeit
und es stimmt ja eben auch dass von den
als bedrohlich empfundenen fremden
besonders viele straftaten begehen also
muss man hier gezielt intervenieren wie
könnte das aussehen
ich nenne das ganze konzept doppelten
spurwechsel ich möchte dass verkehr der
anreiz system richtig aufbauen wir haben
ein system in unserem land in dem
geflüchtete vor allem abgelehnte die
400.000 die sie ansprechen sich
anstrengen können wie sie wollen sie
dürfen trotzdem nicht bleiben und
straftaten begehen können in großem
umfang und sie kommen trotzdem nicht ins
gefängnis keine sanktionen keine
belohnungen
das ist offenkundig eine faire anreiz
und das würde ich kann genau umgedreht
machen und sagen wer sich anstrengt wir
unsere gesetze geachtet wer
integrationsbereitschaft zeit die
sprache lernt und einen job annimmt was
tut was unsere gesellschaft dann auch
ein beitrag zurück gibt der darf bleiben
wer jetzt vier oder fünf jahre her ist
bekunden daueraufenthaltsrecht unter
diesen bedingungen egal wie der
asylantrag ausging und auf der anderen
seite möchte ich dass wir abschiebe
bemühungen polizeiliche interventionen
und eben auch die verbringung in sichere
einrichtungen auf die konzentrieren
die ärger machen die straffällig sind
und damit eine gefahr für unsere
bevölkerung und in wir das tun dann
glaube ich dass wir haben sehr viel für
die objektive sicherheit machen aber
auch erklären können den menschen warum
es gar nicht nötig sich zu fürchten weil
wir etwas unternehmen um das problem in
griff zu bekommen
wie viele leute haben das gefühl da
passiert nicht das verunsichert sie am
meisten
sie haben das buch was sie gerade
erwähnt haben mit einer widmung versehen
diese widmung hast für meine eltern die
mir gezeigt haben was ein klarer
standpunkt ist und sie gelten als jemand
querdenker rebell wie auch immer man sie
bezeichnen mag bei den grünen als jemand
der sich nicht danach orientiert was die
partei vor gibt nur ist die partei im
augenblick so erfolgreich wie nie tja
wie stellen sie sich denn dieser partei
jetzt sagen sie weiterhin ich sag
einfach was ich will auch wenn das nicht
parteilinie ist denn sie haben ja auch
in der partei erhebliche aggressionen
schon fast gegen sie hervor
es trifft zu was ich sagen da gibt es
ganz erhebliche konflikte
ich freue mich total über diese
großartigen wahlergebnisse wie sie jetzt
in hessen und bayern erzielt wurden das
sind viele meiner langjährigen freunde
jetzt sehr erfolgreich gewesen und ich
bin auch die umfragewerte bei denen
herbig und werbung eine große rolle
spielen hervorragend ist alles super ich
glaube aber das ist meine aufgabe ist in
meiner partei auf ein problem aufmerksam
zu machen im moment ist dieser siegeszug
das ergebnis des zerfalls von spd und
teilweise auch der union
das heißt alle die eine weltoffene
politik und politik gegen rechts haben
wollen kommen zu uns die verlassen die
beiden großen volksparteien früher
großen volkspartei aber auf der anderen
seite ist unsere sehr klare position
einer der gründe warum sich immer mehr
leute vor den beiden volksparteien zur
afg verabschieden weil sie sich von uns
nicht wagen doch nicht ernst genommen
fühlen und uns als die eigentliche
bedrohung in ihrem land betrachten
ironischerweise und worauf ich drauf
hinarbeitet ist eigentlich nur dass wir
diese sensibilität für diejenigen haben
sie uns nicht wählen werden aber in
gefahr sind zur afg abzuwandern und dass
wir weil wir ein extrem verkörpern in
der politischen debatte in der
verantwortung haben zu vermeiden dass
die gesellschaft in der mitte durch
reist und nur noch zwei lager sich
bekämpfen ich möchte den versuch machen
dass auch die grünen sich um die themen
können man die ihre wählerschaft gar
nicht besorgen aber wenn wir wenn wir
mal gucken bei umfragen
sie haben gerade die beiden
wahlergebnisse während in bayern und in
hessen um die 20 prozent wir haben eine
umfrage für die bundesweite akzeptanz
der grünen oder zustimmung zu den grünen
von 23 prozent
die hälfte der deutschen bevölkerung
kann sich theoretisch vorstellen grün zu
wählen dass eine euphorie die es so noch
nie gegeben hat ist das nicht genau der
teil dem dann ein anderer teil entgegen
steht den sie gerade erwähnt haben der
eben vielleicht nicht pro europäisch
sind wie sich die grünen geäußert haben
vielleicht nicht den klimaschutz als das
wichtige thema ansieht vielleicht
die migration anders regeln will dass
wir doch in deutschland zu einer
aufteilung kommen wie wir sie im ausland
überall sehen zwischen populisten und
denjenigen die versuchen noch zu retten
was zu retten ist
jedenfalls kann man die sorge haben und
wir grünen müssen dabei eine
verantwortung übernehmen die über die
menschen hinaus reicht die uns wählen
das ist meine kernthese der vergleich
mit den usa wahrscheinlich am
treffendsten total gespalten das land
ohne mitte hat große probleme
es besteht dann halt auch die gefahr
dass die andere seite dem fall die um
donald trump auch mal wahlen gewinnt
obwohl man selber dabei sehr stark
abschneiden das kann uns also nicht
genug sein als grüne so viele stimmen zu
bekommen weil das werden wir in bayern
ausgeben mit 18 prozent der opposition
eben doch nicht bedeutet dass man seine
ziele auch in der regierung weiß
erreichen kann
überdies nicht ganz das erste mal das
gab's schon mal 2011 nach der wahl mit
kretschmann dass die grünen so gute
werte hatten bundesweit ich hoffe dass
es diesmal gelingt sie dauerhaft zu
verstetigen dauerhaft verstetigen heißt
aber auch substanz zu zeigen und nicht
nur terminologie also im sinne von wir
sind pro klimaschutz pro europa wir sind
für eine einwanderungspolitik was sind
denn dann die grünen elemente
sie sind grüner und sie sind bewusst
grüner geworden
sie haben sich zunächst mal in den
landtag wählen lassen in baden
württemberg sehr haben für grüne politik
gestalten sie haben unglaublich oft mit
setzen
ressentiments und und reaktionen
hervorgerufen
die hießen schmeißt den doch aus der
partei heraus der ist ja überhaupt nicht
auf der linie
was ist dein grüne politik aus ihrer
sicht grün ist für mich zunächst einmal
umweltschutz naturschutz und klimaschutz
deswegen bin ich dieser partei
beigetreten und nach wie vor sind wir
die einzigen die dieses thema so ernst
nehmen dass wir auch entsprechend
handeln
da kann ich in tübingen auch meinen
kritikern einiges entgegen halten
wir haben in den zehn jahren meiner
amtszeit dem co2 ausstoß pro kopf um 32
prozent gesenkt und es bei einem
wirtschaftswachstum von 25 prozent
gemessen an arbeitsplätzen
also mehr wohlstand und weniger schaden
amt ist das übertragbar auf die
bundesebene ich bin überzeugt dass es
übertragbar ist denn wir haben uns ja
innerhalb der bestehenden gesetze bewegt
wir haben nur entschlossen und
entschieden gehandelt wir haben zb den
anteil der erneuerbaren energien aus
eigener produktion der stadtwerke von
unter 10 auf über 50 prozent gesteigert
in nur fünf jahren so was ist machbar
wenn man nur will
und das ist für mich der kern grüner
politik nachhaltigkeit im ökologischen
bereich natürlich geht weit darüber
hinaus wir wollen jetzt partei für alles
sein
ich finde auch der begriff der grünen
volkspartei gut die soziale frage ist
für die grüne basis mindestens so
wichtig wie die ökologische und da ist
das wohnungs thema im moment akut
entscheiden was haben wir da einen
tübingen getan ein zweites beispiel das
sind gerade im gemeinderat mit einem
beschluss dass bei neuen baugebieten 90
prozent aller wohnungen nur noch
preisgebunden vermietet werden dürfen
obergrenze ist der mietspiegel und ein
drittel der wohnungen muss als
sozialwohnungen gebaut werden sind
starker markteingriff den ich aber
vertreten weil ich glaube dass wir
anders die soziale balance nicht halten
können ich sehe mich als durch und durch
grün
sie sehen sich aber auch weiterhin auch
in ihrem selbstverständnis als rebell
kann man das sagen ich meine sie
übernehmen die tradition ihres vaters
der immer als rebell bezeichnet wurde
ein obstbauer
sie waren ja selber mit ihm oft genug
auf dem markt in tübingen und haben obst
verkauft ist das eine familientradition
die sie fortsetzen wollen also
tatsächlich wird man rebellen meistens
nicht aus freiem entschluss sondern
wieder will
so war es auch bei mir vor 45 jahren ist
kein großes thema ist auch eher
ungewöhnlich als oberbürgermeister den
titel alles rebellen zugeschrieben zu
bekommen weil ich regiere jahre statt
und da kann ich ja nicht gegen mich
selbst regulieren richtig ist dass es
diesen konflikt mit meiner partei in der
flüchtlings und der asylfrage gibt und
da habe ich tatsächlich festgestellt
dass der familiäre prägung und vater der
für seine überzeugung ins gefängnis
gegangen ist 18 monate wegen
beamtenbeleidigung weil er missstände
angeprangert haben sie das damals gut
und nicht so gut
ich habe mich sehr mit ihm solidarisiert
aber natürlich war initiative traurig
es ist schön den vater im gefängnis zu
besuchen können sie mir glauben
er hat an seinem haus geschrieben
eigenen sind und glauben lasse ich mir
nicht rauben solange die menge glaubt
ist leicht zu glauben so was prägt
natürlich und wahrscheinlich kommt es
jetzt stärker durch als es manchem
parteifreund lieber ist aber da würde
ich dazu raten in der partei die auch
schon joschka fischer und jürgen trittin
aus gehalten hat und die konflikte die
man mit farbbeuteln auf parteitagen
ausgetragen hat auch mal den
oberbürgermeister auszuhalten der eine
eigene meinung hat er ja immerhin
begründet und übernehmer auch streiten
kann
wie viele ihrer freunde haben irgendwann
gesagt du musst da mal dich ein bisschen
mehr zurückgehalten
das ist ja ganz furchtbar was du da zum
beispiel auch im internet verbreitet das
ist läuft im grunde genommen den gegnern
einer freiheitlichen ordnung im grunde
in die in die arme das das unterstützt
sie ja fast noch also dass die gegner
einer freiheitlichen ordnung von meinen
einträgen auf facebook oder mein äußeren
profitieren das hat mir niemand gesagt
aber nahezu alle meine freunde haben
gesagt dass die vehemenz mit der ich die
kritik vortragen mir politisch schadet
und dass sie mir dazu raten würden
wieder zurückzunehmen alleinig wollen
sie das ich habe sogar versucht aber es
gelingt mir eigentlich ist es gelingt
mir tatsächlich und so ist der rebell
doch mittendrin im herzen ein rebell
drehen aber es ist noch was anderes ich
bin der festen überzeugung dass diese
debatte über flucht und migration in
deutschland so schief läuft und dass so
viel schaden dabei entsteht dass ich da
einfach nicht schweigend zuschauen kann
das bringe ich mich hin heißt das denn
aber auch sie verzichten ganz bewusst
auf eine möglicherweise ja auch
weiterführende karriere bei den grünen
weil die grünen als bundes partei in
zweifel
sozusagen auf einer general ebene und
auf einer ideologischen ebene sich eher
um einen konsens um einen kompromiss
bemühen müssen den sie im zweifel in
einer stadt mit 90.000 menschen nicht
eingehen müssen
ich habe ja umgekehrt eindruck dass ich
versuche kompromisse zu schmieden die
sehr viel mehr menschen erfassen 1 meine
partei dies zu tun bereit ist die in
flucht fragen halt sehr kompromisslos
eine haltung vertritt den man ja
begründen können die aber vielen
menschen angst macht und bei vielen
großen widerspruch erregt verzichte ich
darauf weist das kann man nicht sagen
ich finde das amt des oberbürgermeisters
von zwillingen ist eines der schönsten
dass die politik auf dieser welt zu
bieten hat ich lade sie gern mal wieder
ein sich die bienen zu gucken dann kann
man das besser verstehen das ist eine
wunderbare stadt ist eine schöne aufgabe
dazu wirken aber ich hoffe auch ein
bisschen drauf dass wieder bessere
zeiten für mich kommen im verhältnis zu
meiner partei der ministerpräsident
kretschmann stellt 1989 mal vom
parteiausschluss weil er gesagt hatte
eine überzeugung auf dem parteitag zu
äußern nämlich die dass müllverbrennung
in zukunft notwendig sein werde
das war damals in sakrileg jürgen
trittin hat 15 jahre später ein gesetz
beschlossen dass alle müllentsorgung die
nicht durch verbrennung geschieht
verboten werden muss so schnell kann's
gehen er wurde rehabilitiert da ist
heute ministerpräsident lag um auch für
mich noch mal ja aber das hört sich ja
so ein klein bisschen danach an dass ein
solcher ja auch deutlich sich äußerte
ministerpräsident kretschmann durchaus
nicht nur vorbild oder freund von ihnen
ist sondern vielleicht auch jemand ist
der den weg beschreitet den dem sie
nachfolgen könnten also nachfolgen im
sinne von ich habe viel mit ihm
gesprochen ich habe viel von ihm gelernt
und er hat mich in vielen situationen
sehr stark unterstützt ja gerne aber
wenn die frage lauten sollte ob ich der
nächste ministerpräsident was sie
eigentlich gemacht werden
da würde dann würde ich sie auf die
üblichen politiker verweisen und im
moment ist es ja recht einfach zu sagen
die voraussetzung dafür wäre dass meine
partei das will das tut sie ganz
offensichtlich nicht haben sie denn die
befürchtung dass sie auf dauer mit ihren
ideen die sie vertreten und diese
vehement vertreten wie sie selber sagen
und manchmal vielleicht auch ein
bisschen zu wenig vertreten
eine partei linie unterstützen können
die ja irgendwann auch mal wenn sie in
einer verantwortung als partei zum
beispiel auf der bundesebene mit
regieren könnte notwendig wird also da
müssen die entscheidungen dann plötzlich
fallen und entscheidungen auch nicht
mehr ideologisch fahren sondern ganz
pragmatisch
wie die die sie in der stadt immer
umsetzen müssen
tatsächlich ist ja genau das passiert
als wir grüne jamaika verhandelt haben
das wurde dann zwar nicht mehr
beschlossen aber wir wissen aus den
berichten dass die grünen gerade in der
flucht und migrationsfrage mit der
einführung einer fiktiven obergrenze mit
der anerkennung der sicheren
herkunftsländer in den maghreb staaten
zugeständnisse gemacht hatten
die sie in der opposition natürlich
nicht machen können auch nicht machen
werden wir bekämpfen das jetzt wieder
aber damals waren wir im gesamtpaket
bereit ist zu unterschreiben und das
zeigt ja und ich finde es auch im wert
den die partei hat dass sie heutzutage
in der lage ist anders als vor 30 jahren
statt fundamentalismus pragmatismus
walten zu lassen wenn es drauf ankommt
verantwortung für das land zu übernehmen
ich bin da sehr optimistisch und dann
sind natürlich auch erfahrungen auf
kommunaler ebene wertvoll
das heißt aber umgekehrt gesagt sie
können sich sehr gut vorstellen in eine
höhere verantwortung auch in der partei
zu gehen
ich bin bereit verantwortung zu
übernehmen ob das höher ist wenn man
also hör mal ich im sinne des amtes sehe
ich gar nicht so das heißt ja auch
oberbürgermeister nicht unter
bürgermeister ich sehe mich da auf einer
höhe wenn sie so wollen
aber ich bin bereit verantwortung zu
übernehmen deshalb in der vergangenheit
gemacht im moment sehe ich die
verantwortung vor allem darin klar und
deutlich zu formulieren was nach meiner
meinung anders sein müsste
wir haben über den rebellen gesprochen
über die familientradition in
anführungsstrichen sagen sie mir noch
mal ein wort darüber warum sie politik
machen warum sie in die politik gegangen
sind und was sie wirklich sozusagen
vorantreibt
sie müssen sich das vorstellen dass ich
so ein 67 jähriger junge
dabei war wie mein vater war
veranstaltungen abgehalten hat und ich
durfte dann den besuchern die 5d mark
stücke die haier männer abnehmen weil er
gegen eintritt veranstaltungen
abgehalten hat zu unterhaltsam waren
seine wahlkämpfe das gibt es heute eher
nicht das man bezahlt und politiker
anzuhören und das hat mich einfach
früher elektrisiert und sozialisiert ich
fand es toll solche volksversammlungen
und mein vater hat mir mitgegeben
schweizer demokratie und umweltschutz
das sind die aufgaben unserer zeit
direkte mitbestimmung der bürgerinnen
und bürger einer freien gesellschaft
und verantwortung für natur und umwelt
und das ist bis heute meine triebfeder
geblieben ist es die rückbesinnung auf
die erfahrung mit ihrem vater oder
treibt sie noch was anderes sagen haben
sie an haben sie neben einer vielleicht
ideologischen auch eine religiöse oder
metaphysische motivation gerade weil sie
sagen die schöpfung muss bewahrt werden
tatsächlich bin ich agnostiker und
können daher diese motivation nicht
beziehen
ich beziehe aber die möglichkeit
durchaus mit ein das gold über uns wacht
und dass er sich freut wenn wir seine
schöpfung bewahren
von daher ist es ja kein schaden die
motivation wird natürlich im laufe des
lebens anders mein vater ist jetzt 14
jahre tot
ich habe jetzt eine zusätzliche
motivation dergestalt dass ich glaube
dass wir in unserer gesellschaft müssen
von unnötigen freunden und verhärtungen
und dass wir zusammen arbeiten müssen
das ist eine große aufgabe haben die
gesellschaft zusammenzuhalten also
integrativ zu wirken im hinblick auf
flüchtlinge aber genauso auf unserer
gesellschaft wie ich sie erlebe und die
basis dafür liegt in den kommunen
deswegen macht mir auch dieses amt so
großen spaß
sind sie denn optimistisch dass wir es
hinbekommen nicht in eine konfrontation
gesellschaft hinein zu geraten wie das
in anderen ländern inzwischen der falsch
der fall ist da bin ich unentschieden
ich sehe chancen aber ich sehe auch die
vielen probleme und risiken und ich bin
in einer stelle damit seehofer einige
ich glaube zentral für die frage ob wir
uns zerlegen und spalten und nicht mehr
miteinander sprechen können oder ob wir
zusammenarbeiten und gemeinsam probleme
lösen ist wie wir die migrations
thematik bewältigen das ist in hinblick
auf streit in unserer gesellschaft
derzeit wirklich die mutter aller
probleme herr papa kannst du ihnen für
das gespräch
danke schön dagegen